thank you good afternoon
councillors members of the staff
members of the public and media please
remain upstanding for the council prayer
on the screen though
almighty god grant to us all needed
guidance wisdom and judgment as we face
the tasks before us
and enable us now and
always worthily to discharge the sacred
trust
placed by the people in our hands amen
now we're live stream streaming today
says if you're aware so welcome to those
who are joining us
the large screen
any apologies
councillor kit and councillor amundsen
for lateness i'd like to move those your
worship
second did you worship moved and
seconded any discussion
questions put it to the vote all in
favor say aye
aye against carried
public forum we have mr
russell williams personal collection
of teddy bears for donation
to speak to that russell welcome to the
meeting
thank you sir and
thank you for your time everybody i've
got a special request
and um i
should also tell you that um sorry
russell could you
get a bit closer to the microphone
i have a special request and i should
also mention
that um from day one i've been told i'm
a little
a little bit crazy especially when i i
built
uh first tumor television in mccargall
and they said no one's going to come and
stay in a motel
and ricardo and so i've been a little
bit crazy ever since and
so tom remembers me from a long way back
but that's a long time ago
yeah um now i've got a particular
thing to ask all of you ladies and
gentlemen
uh i'm a
favorite of the i've always favored the
the museum and loved it
and uh walked queens park and i've
traveled the world for years and and uh
haven't seen much better
places anywhere in the world um
i've got an idea for our
old museum and
it would need a complete engineer's
report on whether it would work or not
and as i said i've always been a bit
crazy and you might think it's a bit
crazy but
if you put four beams
big strong beams up the four
points of the museum to the top
uh and they were big strong beams
and it had to be done by engineers and
that sort of thing
they could be secured at the bottom
with a pretty good lump of concrete
they can be welded together at the top
and uh you could even have an ornamental
bowl or something like that up the top
would look good
and then they could be
disguised by a round
piece of uh just ordinary iron that
the the museum's been covered with
and you wouldn't see the beams and then
they would be introduced to
the original beams of the they'd only be
the width of a few inches from the
original beams of of the
museum and this whole thing would have
to be it sounds easy to talk about it
but it would have to be
done through you know experienced
engineers and that sort of thing
and the idea being that the museum
itself could be saved
and and then strength
strengthened and i i have a
a special idea that
uh children from all around the world
and i mean all around the world would be
uh
allowed to go and see a special uh
exhibition that i've got and i'll donate
this exhibition it's a
the biggest toy collection i've ever
seen anywhere
and and so the children would be
free to go in there but of course uh
hopefully i would sell a few of my bits
and pieces
to to their their
uh so there's not just a total
generous idea of mine i'll donate the
whole
teddy bear i'll go to 10 degrees quickly
that's just incredible i've never seen
any anything better in the world
and uh so the children would see this
teddy bears picnic would be free to them
and then hopefully uh the museum would
sell stuff make some money and
and i would sell some of my uh
things i've got a whole stack of these
sections by sheer coincidence
the lady that was doing these was
on the hills out of christchurch and the
earthquake
wiped her out and i bought
the bits and pieces that she had left
and she was totally heartbroken
and so i helped her by buying half a
dozen pieces
some none finished and she's gone to
uh orphan now and is doing well i i
believe that she's doing well again
and good luck to her um
i don't want to take too long on this
but
it's it's an idea that i'd like it taken
further and uh
it would save the the original museum
and and uh it could be added to if
you've i know you've got big plans but
i also see in the newspaper regularly
how much it's going to cost
and i'd say that my idea of
strengthening the whole museum
and opening it again
without too much damage to be done and
and making it all legal and and
attractive to people uh is is an
alternative
and it can be added to the museum could
be added to but this would
return return the the original museum
and i bought this along just to show you
um a couple of her paintings i bought
everything she had
and the interesting thing was that this
is a a
photo of a bay on her coast
i have another one of uh of stuart
island bay
and this particular one is it's a
tuatara
of which we're talking about we're
talking about the
the museum and the tiotaras
all right russell i have to ask you to
wind it up please
i'm sorry if you could just wind up the
presentation
as interesting as it is yes well i think
i've got
i've got the presentation i've got the
idea
and then it's going to take a lot of
talking and a lot of idea a lot of
carrying up but thank you very much for
your time
thank you move on to the interest
register
is there any changes there
receiving and confirming the minutes
stop it
the minutes of the meeting held on the
27th of april
moved your worship second did you
worship moved and seconded any
discussion
questions put it to the vote all in
favor say aye aye
against carried and it's of the
extraordinary meeting
of the performance policy and
partnership committee
held on the 11th of may 2021
almost now i received your worship uh
second as your worship
all right mention the change of spelling
for my name please
thank you with those amendments i'll put
it to the vote all in favor say aye
against carried
minutes of the performance policy
partnerships committee held on the 11th
of may
be received moved again you wish
it's moved second did your worship moved
and seconded
new discussion questions put it to the
vote all in favor say
aye all right he's carried
minutes of the extraordinary meeting of
the infrastructural services committee
held on the 11th of
may old move that they be received your
worship
i'll second those your worship moved and
seconded any discussion
questions put it to the vote all in
favor say
aye aye it's carried
minutes of the extraordinary meeting of
the performance policy and partnership
committee held on the
18th of may if they received your
worship
moved second did you worship you can do
discussion questions put it to the vote
all in favor say aye against carried
uh we have two three items
on the public agenda
i'll move
how do we put these
okay
the reporter on change
on paper still we have a report from
peter thompson
executive manager
to change the june 2021
council meeting date the change he's
proposing uh that
he we received a report on the change of
june 2021
council meeting date i'll move the three
recommendations
thank you those three items
let's move just for a second
moved and seconded any discussion
questions
put it to the vote all in favor say aye
aye
against kerry
we have another meeting from jeff grant
thank you your worship um i'm just
reporting back
to the council on behalf of the project
governance group
that's second report to the council
which is
in your board papers there are six
recommendations
the first two are just first noting in
the second one
is the uh noting of the working on
working together framework
um staff are currently giving you an a3
as you'll be aware that we shifted in
terms of the working groups from five
down to four
and this is an updated with including
the deliverables
which sets out for um
i'll just mention in a moment but around
the strategic process can you just
please note
since this was printed that support for
councillors
working group has now got um councillor
sopa
as the chair and uh councillor
crackit as the deputy chair which are
not noted on the actual piece of paper
you've got
so the recommendation also for council
to consider
is then three which was
uh the proposal to look at the new
revised terms of reference so in
the second report
we have set out that at the
recommendation
of the work done under lindsay mckenzie
in the strategic projects area there was
a discussion about this and that was to
post the ltp was to look at our process
to
review what had been done during that
process and some learnings for setting
up
the future work on strategic
priorities for projects and then on to
the next ltp so that's the work
to do it's got a finite period and once
that's completed
um it will report back through the pgg
and the council recommendation for
is just the for three parts
some of the work that's come out of the
[Music]
excuse me media protocols and bringing
the community along
working group has had a paper from
uh on the media communications it has a
recommendation for
uh three parts which is clarified
communications and media processes for
elected members
scheduled fortnightly ce and leadership
team briefings on the projects and
establish a
scheduled face-to-face briefings on
project as it's
set out in the appendix uh there's just
a bit more detail on there
this was just uh first of the more
immediate
aspects of the communications framework
to be worked on
and asking for council to consider those
changes for the kpis for the there's
recommendation number five
and then in recommendation number six is
the setting out confirming of the budget
of 420 000
for the 21 22 year and just
please note in terms of the turnout for
the july july 1st sorry june the 30th on
this
current budget uh was budgeted to
310 for the financial year and it's
looking more likely to be around
238 that's all to report
thank you it's just a second after that
receiving that report
and the recommendations and the
recommendations
i'll move all the recommendations your
worship
i'll second those your worship it's
moved and secreted
any questions discussion put it to the
vote all in favor say
aye all right against carried
now i'm on the page here other pages are
the same
worship in terms of the page numbers
so where am i on this one
um
oh so if we go forward to the mayor's
report
i'll may that be received so you could
have
seconded it and
oh counselor thank you
your worship i just wanted to
mention one of the things listed on your
mural report the official opening of the
southland software complex
that was a very positive opening event
which councillor scout and i also
attended
and because it is something of a unique
multi-use summer winter facility
development
and i was there in my role as council's
active communities committee chair
i just wanted to say a couple of things
firstly
to acknowledge the role of our previous
parks and reserve managers
robin pagan and michelle frye and their
staff
in providing assistance to that project
mainly around relocation and logistics
work
i know that that took quite a bit of
staff time
and resource and i think it is good for
council to acknowledge that
also after significant due diligence
council's active communities committee
did offer
the project the largest ever low
interest loan that committee has
offered a hundred and fifty thousand
dollars
i understand this was then used by the
project
in applying to other funders for grants
and that was evidence of significant
bridging community
backing for the project and in fact
applications for the grants were then so
successful
in the use of enthusiastic volunteers
from the
softball clubs and the queen's park afc
club was so extensive that the project
did not
did not need to pick up the loan
facility in the end
[Music]
having viewed the facility and i'm sure
councillor
scout would agree i i congratulate the
softball association
and the associated queens park afc
on achieving a great multi-use new
facility
which i think will certainly stand the
test of time
in the surrey part environment so i just
just wanted to note that particular
event
and particularly the contributions from
council staff
and committee thank you thank you for
that report
any further reports or yes counseling
your worship just a couple of quick ones
if you could just give me a bit of an
update on
what transpired with lindsey buckingham
with the southern steam
trail trust and i guess a similar
inquiry about the uh
meeting you had with david bennett who's
from the salvation army and with his
things that they're asking of counsel
um that item was raised by
lindsay buckingham he came to visit me
on behalf of the southern steam trust
and i'm the patron of it okay
and i think unless it's out of date that
councillor lewis
kitten abbott are also
trustees of you worship i don't recall
ever being asked to be your trustee on
that
steam trust oh it surprises me too
you worship okay maybe it's just out of
date
so i'll go back to him on that
and he was really just wanting to know
how to
fund an application on behalf of the
steam train
and he would be applying to the council
for that
in terms of the
r p i together with the araru
[Music]
oyster fishing industry and local
authorities
issued a rahui in controlled area notice
where fishing
and dredging the area of 30
square kilometers
and it hasn't been fished for five years
and only three oysters actually tested
positive
so there's plenty of oysters available
in other areas
biosecurity new zealand is working with
crota holders
in naitahu on future management
anemia has no effect on food safety
and short to medium-term prognosis for
the beads
is good and it's good news
and finally i had a meeting with major
david
bennett the salvation army and that was
just
a sort of meet and greet and a general
discussion
on welfare especially as it affected
teenagers
i think they were the three did you have
any thank you thank you for that
any other issues counsellors wish to
raise
thank you well i thank members of the
public and press for their presence
iris move that
he seconded that the we moved to the
public excluded session
for the confirmation of minutes of the
public excluded session of the 27th
april receiving the minutes of the
public excluded session
of the performance policy and
partnership committee held on the
11th of may and receiving the minutes of
the public excluded session of the
extraordinary
meeting of the performance policy
and partnerships committee held on the
18th of may
happy to second that you worship with
the inclusion that jeff grant lindsay
mckenzie be
included in those allowed to stay thank
you
it's moved in second of that amendment
put it to the voucher all in favor say
aye aye
against gary
thank you for your attendance
you